and book TV org next on public lives
Nina burly's the stranger and the
Statesman the story of 19th century
British philanthropist James Smithson
whose legacy includes the Smithsonian
Institution in Washington DC this is an
hour
thank you okay thank you very much now I
echo first I'd like to say thank you so
much for coming out I have lived in
Washington before I spent many years
here actually and I know that there are
many things to do here besides come to
here Nina Burleigh talk about John
Quincy Adams and james smithson not the
least of which are the two big baseball
games going on right now um having being
from Chicago I'm quite intrigued by
what's happening there especially to
that poor fan but I'd like to just start
by saying um I get a lot of questions
about why I chose this subject being a
journalist somebody who covers
contemporary events and having done that
for a long time and the reason is that
as a journalist I'm always looking for
good stories and this is a really good
story and it's the kind of story that
it's a quiet story and it kind of grew
on me it was recommended to me by a book
editor in New York some years ago and
because I've lived in Washington she
thought i'd be interested in it and I
hadn't heard this story I knew about
this Smithsonian of course I'd lived
here i'd been on the mall and i was
interested in Washington history but I
hadn't heard the story of james smithson
knew nothing about it and i looked into
it and at first I wasn't sure it was
something that I was going to go into
partly because 18th century history is a
long long time ago and it's not easy to
recreate those times or I wasn't sure if
I was going to be able to do that and
also because James Smithson the title of
the book is
stranger and the statesman James
Smithson was a stranger in the 1830s
when word of his bequest first reached
the Americans and he is to this day
something of a stranger and my research
into him I dug up some interesting
tidbits things that are known to a few
people probably already I don't know how
many experts are in the audience here
from the Smithsonian and I'm not going
to ask you to raise your hands because
you'll make me really nervous but uh
there are some things in this book that
will be new to you to those who know a
lot about it but mostly what I tried to
do was bring to life this man x and his
world and the world of the Americans who
received the money at the time when in
the 1830s when they heard so i'll just
start with i'll give you a little bit of
background on him i'm not going to give
all the tidbits away because i want you
to read the book but i'll start with the
basic story is that in 1835 President
Jackson received word that an Englishman
had left five hundred thousand dollars
to the United States to found at
Washington and institution called the
Smithsonian for the diffusion excuse me
for the increase and diffusion of
knowledge among men now there were a lot
of troubling things about this but the
main thing that troubled Jackson was
that nobody knew who this man was nobody
had ever heard of him he was English
that was a problem and I'll get to that
in a minute but the first thing is who
was who was this man who was James
Smithson
he was the illegitimate son of one of
the richest men in England man named
Hugh Smithson Duke of Northumberland the
Northumberland to this day are among the
richest people in England they own huge
swathes of London they're billionaires
Hugh Smithson was a man who wasn't born
to the title he married the heiress who
was who owned the the properties and he
became Duke through his wife giving up
in the process his own name and taking
hers which men in the 18th century did
when they married of a more prominent
woman in the 18th century in England
Smithson James Smithson born in France a
lot of tourists walking around them all
see the signs Smithsonian Smithsonian
Smithsonian they may have gone and to
the Capitol restaurant and eaten some
freedom fries before they see these
signs and they won't know that Smithson
was born Jacques may see in Paris and he
was a French boy AG arsal until he was
10 years old when his mother the
adventurous and adventurous Elizabeth
may see mistress of the duke of
northumberland brought him back to
England and had him naturalized as a as
an English boy he was educated at Oxford
he became a scientist collected minerals
analyzed them at a time when mineralogy
when really science was not divided into
categories that we now call mineralogy
or geology when he collected minerals
there's a mineral named after him which
we all know as the white stuff that
lifeguards we're on there
it's called zinc oxide but it's called
smithsonite I don't want to give away
everything about him so I'm just going
to flip over to his at the end of his
life the Smithsonian had a forensic
scientist examine his bones so we know
that when he died he had lost 17 teeth
and he may have played a stringed
instrument and you can ask me more
questions about him at the end because I
don't want to give it all away before
but I do want to talk a little bit about
his times because he lived at a time he
lived it at an at what I this is
something that kept me interested in
this in this story while I was working
on it he lived at a time of it was on
the edge a very great change and almost
all the changes had to do with science
that the change between our time and his
for example electricity they didn't
really understand what electricity was
at the end of the 18th century they
thought it was a liquid but there were
people who were beginning to understand
that it wasn't a liquid and they were
beginning to understand what it is and
beginning to make experiments that laid
the groundwork for people to invent
light bulbs and to create kind of
electronic systems that we now are
accustomed to atomic system he was
Smithson was analyzing minerals to get
down to their elements the table of
elements was being created then
chemistry as we know it was being
created then but the atomic system was
not understood the atom of course wasn't
understood speed I used to take the
Chunnel train from Paris to London
because a lot of the material for this
book was in London that which isn't at
the Smithsonian already and I'd sit
there on that train going 200 miles an
hour and think about this quote that I
dread which isn't in the book by one of
the nobles who would want to Smith since
contemporaries who had decided to take a
little ride on the locomotive that had
just been invented around then and he
wrote I'm paraphrasing he wrote we took
a lark of great order today we went on
this train and it took it went 15 miles
an hour and I had such a headache after
after this I don't think I'm going to
recover for weeks and I was going two
hundred miles an hour on this train and
thinking about these this difference but
and then more morbidly nobody in Smith's
ins generate life time would have
reached my age 40 something and not have
lost family members children parents
best friends to death to their medical
system was so primitive it was behind
even what the scientists scientists were
McAmis were figuring out and they died
of things that we would have that we
easily survived now with one dose of
penicillin so it was a different time so
he leaves this money to the United
States and I get a lot of questions why
did he leave the money well I can't
answer that he left his we left he left
a will that originally left the money to
his nephew had the nephew lived this
would have never come to the United
States one of the many serendipitous
events that led to this money coming
here the nephew died early but you know
with the money why did he leave half a
million dollars to the Americans was he
crazy possibly some people the early
Americans
saw his will kind of thought that and
actually one of them wrote that in a
letter back one of the charged affair
and England wrote back possibly not of
sound mind was he trying to get revenge
on the on the British who had not
accepted him as a member of the nobility
because his father was the Duke of
Northumberland but he really wasn't he
was an illegitimate son possibly that
has been proposed also was he trying to
put his name on something as rich people
do now put a name on a wing of a museum
or a hospital or at college possibly but
that wasn't common then so he may have
there were people who were doing it but
but I think the most likely reason that
he left the money to the Americans
having never set foot here having
probably not known any Americans is that
he had an idea about this country that
was very flattering to us and it was
that shared with the other members of
his intellectual group during that era
the Enlightenment that you know America
was a place where because we had
codified the new nation and codified
freedom of speech and was a classless
society officially that that this was
the best place to from which to increase
and diffuse knowledge among the greatest
number of people in England very few
people at that time were educated and
the Reformers educational reformers of
the time which he was a member of one of
the groups that were kind of involved
with William Blake others they used this
language for the increase in diffusion
of knowledge among men so he probably
thought that America was the best place
to from which is this could happen
however
in 1830s the reality of America was not
exactly living up to the ideal of the
Europeans the enlightened Europeans and
in the founders who had thought that who
thought that America might become a new
Athens and definitely Washington DC was
not the place from which cultural where
you would place a cultural institution
people would have thought of Boston or
New York or Philadelphia but not
Washington but he had he had specified
Washington so the money arrived and the
American politicians were tasked with
figuring out how to diffuse knowledge
among men from Washington DC and I'm
going to read to you a section because
we're in Washington that has to do with
this um Washington history what
Washington was like when this money came
here and I'll keep it short so you won't
fall out of your chairs Washington City
in the early 19th century was more like
a frontier town than the seat of
national government vast areas of the
city were forests or scrub interrupted
by muddy construction sites some of the
buildings we recognize today the Capitol
the White House had just been built and
gleamed an incongruous white above acres
of wild marshland workmen lured from the
bigger American cities in Europe were
just piling up the great stone blocks of
the Treasury Building the capital city
was the capital city climate was
unforgiving for people living in an era
before cars and air conditioning in
winter fog and icy mud made travel
treacherous if not impossible steaming
summers brought mosquitoes and malaria
cholera epidemics raged annually besides
the threat of disease in the and the
city's awkward muddy newness Washington
had a CD dangerous edge high culture
fine arts theater music was nearly
non-existent within this
city and many of the elected officials
who bunked there during legislative
sessions held a view shared by many
Americans but such things were wasteful
maybe even harmful to the vigor of the
new nation side arms chewing tobacco hip
flasks were Capitol Hill accoutrement
foremost office holders hunting dogs
shared floor space with congressmen in
the house fist fights broke out at
presidential parties inside the white
house when the Smithson bequests derived
Washington newspapers were running front
page ads desperately seeking women to
come to Washington to be wives to the
stone workers on the treasury building
the American writer and royal visited
the Capitol around this time and she was
horrified she saved her deepest outrage
for the denizens of the Capitol building
which we architecture what she loved and
I'll just read you her one of her
comments of all sites that ever
disgraced a house of legislation and one
which most astonishes a stranger is the
number of abandoned females which swarm
in every room and nook in the Capitol
even in daylight I've seen these females
with brazen fronts seated in the
galleries listening to the debates they
used to mix promiscuous Lee with the
respectable class of females until mr.
clay assigned them a place by themselves
mr. clay certainly does deserve much
credit for this public homage to virtue
there was another more grotesque aspect
to Washington City at this time one that
never failed to appall visitors from
foreign lands in spite of the best
efforts of abolitionists and some
congressmen to stop it slaves were still
bought and sold on the banks of the
Potomac within sight of the steps of the
Capitol shackled slaves sometimes
shuffled by and pitiful condition one
writer described the sickening scene
from the Capitol doors quote a
procession of men women and children
tumbling that of a funeral bound
together in pairs some with ropes some
with iron chains unquote the city jail
was sometimes described as a storehouse
for slave merchants even freed blacks of
whom there was a growing population in
Washington at the time were in danger of
being kidnapped and sent back to the
south so that's Washington when the
money arrived when the money when word
of this month the availability of the
money arrived they sent to they sent a
diplomat over to get it it took about
two years for the money actually to get
here in the form of gold coins they
transferred stocks they sold stocks put
the money into gold coins put the gold
coins and bags onto a ship and the
diplomat Richard rush took a very
seasick ride with this gold this
treasure hoard across the Atlantic and
before I even got here as he was
actually he had gotten here he's putting
the money into the mint in Philadelphia
the money had already been spent had
been put somewhere by Congress and that
story you can ask me about but basically
the money was taken by a villain from
Arkansas there's always a villain from
Arkansas isn't there but this leads me
to the other person on the title The
Statesman the statesman in the story is
John Quincy Adams scholar politician I
know an oxymoron and his he was at this
point in time serving in the house he
was no longer president he had come back
and he had lost the presidency to
Jackson partly because he was not a very
great politician I think and he
given a lot of he put a lot of effort
futile effort into persuading Congress
to make the federal government more
active in cultural things his cultural
scientific intellectual endeavors his
big sort of pet project was to create a
national observatory which never
happened but he was thrilled to hear
that this money was a road coming to the
United States for the purpose of
diffusing knowledge among men because he
believed that knowledge was going to
save men from sin he had written us in
his diary and he was a very nah he was a
very educated man and he was and he was
also we represented the abolitionists in
Congress from his district there were a
lot of abolitionists petitioning
Congress begging them to stop the slave
trade at least on the banks of the
Potomac outside of the capital and what
happened was the southerners managed to
pass something called the gag or gag
order gag rule sorry gagra gag orders a
court in court he managed and he was so
he was stopped really from bringing
these petitions forward and this was the
subtext of American politics when this
money arrived the slavery the discussion
of slavery had been silenced and yet it
was a huge issue in Congress in people's
minds and especially for people like
Adams very moral and very learned man
who would sit in his office could see
this thing happening outside his window
so I'll just read a little bit from
about Adams and quote from his diary he
was a very prolific diarist and his
diaries are available at the library of
congress and
that's where I got this information but
I'm going to i'm just going to read to
you a little bit about him in his and
talk about his the way he looked at this
money in the winter of 1842 John Quincy
Adams was 74 years old he had become
gnome-like with age his bald head and
pale round face tinged the unhealthy
pink of a man who would soon begin to
suffer debilitating strokes only the
black eyes with their steady piercing
look remained of the younger man's visit
from the study in his house on F Street
in Washington or his rooms at the adams
farm in Quincy the ex-president still
habitually worked late into the night
once the Sun had set the darkness
outside was always complete except for
the light of the moon in that pre
motorized pre electric era night silence
was disturbed only by the clip-clop of a
passing horse and buggy or the isolated
call of a bird on clear nights Adams
could step outside and look at the stars
in the black vacuum of space in the
waning years of his life disappointed by
politics and the moral weaknesses of his
fellow office holders Adams looked
skyward with an ever more wistful prayer
he still desperately wanted to see
America enter what he called the sublime
'used science astronomy Adams tried to
record in his diary why he felt so
passionately about the mechanical
workings of the universe late in his
life the perceived motion movement of
stars moon and sun had a spiritual
relevance for him quote I saw the Sun
rise and set clear from Charles's house
on the hill the pleasure that I take in
witnessing these magnificent phenomena
of physical nature never tires it is a
part of my own nature unintelligible to
others the sensations which affect me at
the rising and Setting Sun our first
adoration to the power and goodness of
the Creator mingled in the morn
with Thanksgiving and in the evening
with sadness and with humble
supplication for forgiveness of my own
errors and infirmities unquote he had
hoped that with Smith sins money he
would quote witness the means of
increasing and diffusing favorable
knowledge among men by systematic and
scientific series of observations on the
phenomena of the numberless world's
suspended over our heads the sublime
estuve the physical sciences unquote it
was not to be there was no as no
Observatory was built with this money
instead after many years money had been
stolen replaced much dithering and on
Capitol Hill Adams with the help of some
other progressives passed a bill that
created this institution for the
diffusion of knowledge among men and
what did they do with the money first
they built a castle for the man who had
been barred at the moat literally
figuratively in England they built a
castle and a castle rose out of this
muck that was the mall and they put his
name on it and that was the first of
many many as you now know buildings that
crew that surround the mall and that
diffuse information knowledge among
everyone who visits them I was talking
about this in New York the other day and
somebody came up to me and physicist and
said you know when I was a kid I my
parents dragged me over to the air and
space museum and I hated it I didn't but
now would be made it made me become a
scientist so it did diffuse knowledge
among men but possibly not in the way
that the founders of the institution
imagined it would and and who knows what
smithson thought it would become and
I'll end there and please ask me some
questions because we have some time if
you're interested I have there's lots of
information in here and lots of facts
and history any questions yes mention
that the time period that Smithson lived
in was right on the edge of the mud what
I would call the modern years that's
right how much you think the
intellectuals of the time realized that
that's hard to answer I mean did they
know that there would be a time when
fireplaces wouldn't be needed to heat
their homes could they imagine the light
bulb no I don't think so I mean they
were still trying to figure out whether
electricity was liquid or not but I
think they knew that I mean there was a
great deal of excitement especially in
geology which this man entered it was
kind of like people going into I don't
know microchip studies what he could you
know electronics in the 70s or right you
know rocket science before I mean they
were excited about it and a lot of young
men were entering it they were trying to
classify they were looking at the earth
you know at the time the clerics
believed they had a date exactly how
many years old the earth was and men
like Smithson Macy was his name then in
Oxford they knew that there was
something other than that that the truth
was other than that and that the
scientists knew that and they were they
were arguing among themselves what
possibly could be this or the origin of
this planet that we live on if it's not
that it's only 5,000 years old because
these rocks seem to indicate that
maybe it's millions of years old I mean
they were starting to figure that out
and they were starting to figure out the
atomic system and but did they know that
they could they envisioned I don't know
the a-bomb or light bulb or I don't
think so did they envision that the you
know that there would be at a time when
people could have root canal done
painlessly no doubtful you know so but I
think they knew that they were on I mean
there was a great deal of excitement in
science at that time most of it was a
lot of it was in France in Paris and and
Lavoisier putting together the the table
elements and chemistry but i don't know
i don't think that they could envision
to the degree to which they were on the
edge yes sirree problem some of the
political problems that caused the delay
from when the money arrived to Congress
set up the institution
um good question yet there were well
okay the money arrived and the political
problems were that the southerners and
others didn't want the federal
government to expand and this money and
indicate wood to make in federal
institution we indicated an expansion of
the federal government and they didn't
they didn't want that it was an
encroachment on states rights they
thought it was not a good idea for the
federal government to expand into
education or that was what this was
viewed as possibly an educational
institution they didn't want to see that
happen and so that was one of the big
issues there was also a lot of
indifference to it I think there wasn't
a great deal I mean Adams was very
excited about it but most people were
either baffled most politicians were
either baffled by it or didn't care or
were offended because this remembers an
Englishman giving the money and had only
been a couple of decades since we've
been at war with the British and at this
time still congressman made a sport
basically of of attacking the British in
their speeches kind of like they do with
France now or something they make they
never let a moment an opportunity pass
to ridicule the British so that's coming
from an Englishman was an added problem
so there was that and you know they
didn't know what to do with it they
didn't know how to diffuse knowledge
among men what was that how are they
going to manifest that idea and whether
it would be a popular institution all
right you know a lot of people wanted it
to be an edgy cacao Jorm you known as
school and Adams fought against that
because
he had not Smithson had not said this is
for a school he said among men knowledge
among men not among youth so they didn't
go into a school but there was that was
that was it really was it was it was a
issue of whether the federal government
would become larger and go into the
cultural realm I think that was a big
part of it Adams worried that if they
set up a research institution or college
and would compete with Harbor
I didn't see any evidence of that in the
Diaries but I can't answer that i don't
i don't know i mean he was what he was
concerned about was that people would
take the money and you know there was
one of the Senators wanted to take the
money and set himself up as the as the
head of a new university and he was very
concerned throughout the discussions
that somebody was going to try to enrich
himself with this money and in fact that
did happen very early on and he had to
shame the US Treasury into putting up
the money the principal because the it
was gone the ark hands and made off with
it it was gone it stopped paying it
stopped paying very quickly those bonds
stopped paying and they never recovered
it hmm cross the ocean what did the
British in the family do in reaction to
this treasure going to the colonies well
the money wasn't actually northumberland
money the money was amassed by his
mother strangely enough now there there
is no record that nor the Duke gave
Smithson any money but we can assume
because he was generous with his other
illegitimate children we can we know
that through various obituaries and
things we can assume that he was giving
him probably through I don't know other
another name or just putting money into
a bank account for him he was probably
giving money to this boy but what I
found um and that wasn't in the
Smithsonian archives in England the
mother Elizabeth Macy filed nine
lawsuits during her lifetime to protect
her fortune she had inherited money she
was a hungerford which is another old
name in England she had inherited money
in a state actually through her family
and she'd also inherited money from a
husband who died so she was very wealthy
and which he filed lawsuits to fight off
all comers including a husband
fortune-hunting man who she'd married
very bad judgment and and other people
family
and stewards and people who made claims
and this is very unusual in the late
18th century for a woman in England
there were very few rights women didn't
have many property rights and and those
that existed women didn't really know
about so the fact that she was filing
all these lawsuits very telling about
what kind of person she was I think and
we know nothing else about her there are
no letters there are no portraits I mean
I looked high and low in bath and you
know and the area where family lived and
contacted descendants and nothing but
this these lawsuits exist so we know she
was a tough person and had she not been
that way the money wouldn't have gone to
her son because it's clearly the husband
the second husband would have made off
with a huge chunk of it and the family
the Northumberland's have over time
taken various degrees of interest in it
there was a Duke a few Dukes ago who was
very interested in this and communicated
with the Secretary of the Smithsonian
and a lot of his papers are at the
archives and he was giving them sort of
the family lore on it and he really
tried to open up the books and find out
what was going on with that his ancestor
but you know the present Duke isn't all
that interested in it and so but did the
English the English didn't put up a
fight the Americans who went over
Richard rush was the Ambassador the
diplomat that they sent to get it he was
afraid that they would put up a fight
because illegitimate children there were
laws that kept them from giving away
money and you know it Smithson had done
apparently done what he could in
anticipation of that he had he had sold
off the properties and it was all in
paper because there were laws that
didn't allow them to inherit to give
property bastard children so it was all
in paper but the but the British
government did nothing they didn't put
up a fight it was only it only took two
years because of typical court delays
there was a huge backup it was
jarndyce vs. jarndyce kind of situation
so anyway that Siri I came in about five
minutes late but was there an
institution in Europe that Smithson
admired and hope that that might have
been to model for this endowment yes I
mean he was a member a founding member
of something called the royal
institution which is the institutional
to which I alluded earlier that involved
some other reformer types educational
reformers like William Blake are people
who had a hope that scientific
information spread among the largest
number of people would improve society
from for more people and believe it or
not that was a radical idea then I mean
scientists were rich men who you know
you didn't practice you didn't you
weren't a mineralogist if you didn't
have a lot of money and a servant to go
around with you and help you with your
pickaxe and this was not something there
there were no chairs there were no
endowed professorships there was no it's
nothing it was nothing like it is now so
that the Royal Institution it still
exists in England was a place they fit
was one of the founders and it became a
place where people like Faraday an
Englishman who was very instrumental in
understanding electricity could do their
experiments and Faraday was like the son
of a woodcutter and he became one of the
greatest scientists in this of his day
where people could do science and share
it with the public because all this
information was becoming you know these
people were figuring these things out
and they needed to get this out not just
for esoteric reasons but because they
realized and there's another book
written about this about these guys who
decided at that time that like Wedgwood
that it's that this information could be
used for industrial means I mean you
know the industrial
revolution was just beginning then so
this information can be used by I don't
know what we would call yuppies or
professional people to build things and
make things and you know help the
factories and so he was part of that
movement at the Royal Institution and
they even used the same language
increasing and diffusing knowledge in
their charter hmm you'd say that he's a
stranger I mean was he married is there
much known about him at all uh I know
yeah I can answer that you don't want to
read the book and find out no he say was
uh he's a stranger yes he said he
remains a stranger in a lot of ways but
no he was not married we know that um he
had no children he liked to gamble he
was somewhat eccentric somewhat of a
feeble health his mentor at the Royal
Society was extremely eccentric a guy
named henry cavendish brilliant
scientist who figured out things about
the properties of heat long before
people really knew what that what he was
doing was accurate but he was this man
who was so he so loathed females that he
had to leave notes for his maids on the
stairs in his house so that to tell them
what he wanted to eat because he
couldn't deal with them directly and
this was his mentor he was he was an
assistant in Cavendish's lab when he was
a young man but that's not to say that
Smithson shared that kind of feeling but
that he was exceed definitely got along
with other eccentric scientists and he
was in his own way very reticent I think
or they wouldn't have had such a hard
time when the Smithsonian did was
finally created they sent people over to
Europe to try to find things out about
him and they had a really hard time
digging up anything there
living people who would have remembered
him or should have remembered him and
they didn't at that time around the turn
of the century old people who should
have remembered him so he wasn't a very
flamboyant or colorful figure in his
life that's for sure but there's more in
the book about him that him mmm okay
or started
um that's a good question i don't really
know how the public reacted to it i know
that the when it burned when the castle
burned in 1865 a huge crowd came around
and they they were trying to get in
there to get the treasures out well it
was been they had to be beaten back by
the cavalry so they thought there were
treasures in there and interesting
things but one of the reasons it became
a museum as opposed to a scientific
institution a research institution is
that the congressmen who were who they
needed to support it over the Dover time
couldn't really understand it as
something other than sort of a popular
institution a place where that would
collect and archive interesting things
and so it went in that direction they
they financed expeditions early on
interesting expeditions to all sorts of
places and they brought things back and
that's kind of one of the ways it became
started to become a museum against the
the will really of Joseph Henry the
first secretary because this stuff was
piling up and they were bringing things
back from the southwest and I know every
hither and yon and they it piled up and
then there was also a museum that
existed that was that failed and so they
moved all that stuff over and started
and started to become America's addict
and that's that was the the popular
notion of it pretty early on but that's
not what the founders of it really hoped
would happen
as someone who has studied James
Smithson do you have a sense of what was
lost his neighbors and material in that
fire oh boy I wish I could I wish I did
I wish I did I mean there is a little
tiny bit about what it was in that
because one one of the early clerks of
the actually wasn't the Smithsonian
clerk it was he was with another an
ization had gone through it and he had
written taken notes on certain things
but you know so he said you know a lot
of it was about Smithson was very
interested in architecture and buildings
and habitations so he had been taking
notes on these buildings but I need also
but there were also things such as my
blood shall live on beyond the Percy
past the when the Percy blood is
forgotten you know these kinds of
statements that you make you wonder what
was going on in his head was he really
all there and you know how much of a how
much grander did he want to had he tried
to apply to himself and that you know we
can't prove it that that he even said
that because that piece of paper is gone
but but this man decided to write that
down because it fit with the myth or the
legend that they were the legend that
they were trying to create if somebody
who was dissed by the class system of
England so they you know he wrote that
down but the other stuff he really just
summarized and I mean it was thousands
apparently pieces of paper so who knows
what was in there I it's a very sad and
you as an archivist would I mean I would
know it's when that stuff's gone the sad
to see it go so yes what is what's five
hundred thousand dollars in today's
and secondly if he was a gambler is the
duty there's a chance that he thought
that we were not exactly the most likely
but rather the least likely nation to do
something useful with the money and then
because his last gamble on a bunch of
losers or sit here that's a good point
I'm sorry that I didn't include that in
my book you know the how much is the
money worth okay that's um well the CCP
according to economists the seat boy CPI
it's 10 million I had been told when I
was working on the book that it was a
factor of 10 so I included I say it was
worth 50 million and if it's if you
economize calculated by personal income
today it's worth a hundred and fifty
million dollars so there's this vast
range CPI 10 million personal income 150
million it was a lot of money and the
way to understand how much it was is to
look at what other how much people made
then and what other things that were
endowed were worried so Harvard was the
entire endowment of Harvard was six
hundred thousand dollars and he gave
five hundred thousand dollars so it was
a huge sum terms of an endowment and as
to his gambling well he it could very
well be I mean it was nobody knows why
did he put the sentence at the end of
the will it could have been just a
tossed off comment you know he probably
maybe thought that it would never happen
and maybe he did think we were a bunch
of losers I mean certainly the British
media that's what you want to call it at
the time was filled with disparaging
accounts of Americans at this time and
he would have been aware of these
accounts I mean travelers were coming
here and writing about how what bores we
were and you know it was just such a
backwater filled with savages and people
didn't know how to speak French properly
and it was just an awful place and
mosquitos and you know savagery and
Aborigines and so he would have known
that it was certainly was part of the
literature and he read the magazines we
know he read them he had big collection
of popular literature which is one of
the interesting things that did survive
the fire his book collection and that
remains at the Smithsonian and the rare
books section of the Smithsonian and the
librarian there has cat recently catalog
diamond very kindly shared them with me
and and that's quite interesting and was
very helpful because it enabled me to
see for example there was a big volume
about north and somebody's written a
book about traveling in North America in
1799 and he had that it is death so we
assuming knew this is what he thought
about America and he was reading a book
by somebody who was just appalled at the
mosquitoes and the sound of the
bullfrogs they'd never heard such sounds
and he had traveled from you know the
entire East eastern seaboard describing
the people and it wasn't a very
unflattering portrait of the Americans
but it was it was it's very interesting
travelogue because you realize and the
to the Europeans this country was such a
wild place and they had no I mean it's
for scientists especially we're coming
here naturalist's when they saw the
shore there's this quote from humboldt i
mean they saw this shore and they just
filled with this it was like rent wasn't
coming to the moon or something it's
like this new place filled with new
things to see and categorize because
that's what they were all about they
were categorizing they were collecting
and in a way having collections having
the museum be this collection of archive
and archive of material does reflect the
way 18th century scientists thought
about what they were doing or what they
were doing they were categorizing and
collecting and that's what this place is
yes Venice at the time of his death was
he living there he was buried he was in
gentlemen yes a lot of a lot of British
went to Genoa was kind of like their
parrot there there south of France in
fact it was the south of France then it
was France her head recently been or was
it wasn't Italy and he called it the
south of France it was this you know
kind of paradise I mean there's orange
orange groves and you know cheap palazzi
and Byron when Byron went there to take
his you know to do is Greek EU is Greek
expedition and a lot of noble nobility
bought these old palaces and it was a
beautiful place and he really liked the
south of France and throughout his life
these letters he's always indicating
that he's wishing the good that he could
go back to the south of France for his
health to recover his health he wanted
he was always trying to get back there
and so he retired there and then he was
buried there in this British cemetery
but not to rest in peace forever mm-hmm
the nephew unfortunately I had not been
able to find out too much about him
other than what's basically known that
he was he died young at Pisa very young
in his 20s and a former Smithsonian
secretary wrote a book about Smithson in
the 60s indicated that this young man
was kind of a dandy which I guess he was
in it kind of and he oh he did a dandy
who didn't like women or didn't so he
kind of thought that he was saying that
he was gay and he lived this wildlife
and fleshpots of Italy and died early
but I don't know and he did I mean he
did put up a very fancy what I call it
scene of Taff for his uncle and I mean
he had him buried in this and you know
he put up a marble put him in a marble
sarcophagus and he was well buried by
the by the young man and he didn't spend
all the money obviously I mean he had it
under his in his possession for at least
five years before he died he didn't
fritter it all away so that's about it
though that's it
what do you mean a bit of a jerk
anymore
slightly intolerable
arrogant intolerable hmm the swarthy
gentleman oh I wouldn't think he was a
swarthy gentleman i mean he he wrote
he'd the letters that i saw he would he
certainly wasn't a swarthy gentleman he
was a he was a retiring reticent guy
think sort of but to the jerkiness i
mean i guess there you know the letter
some of the letters he signed he signed
saying you know he signed his name it
was aight send yer ongole you kind of
wonder about somebody like you know that
because he's not clearly was not a lord
and english lord so he was put but he
put this title to himself so i think
that that may indicate that he was kind
of puffed up at the end of his life and
kind of behaving or in a kind of not
particularly reticent way at the end and
that may be why people thought he was
crazy I mean that's how I interpreted it
that sender anglais well not exactly the
kind of seconds isn't exactly it wasn't
accurate and he was writing things about
his pedigree so quite early on and kind
of non sequitur fashion in a way that
you would you know people who were
reading it must have been thinking hmm
always what's this but whether he was a
jerk or not I can't answer that you
probably know more about him than I do
mm-hmm
he said something now convince me said
that the nephew died after he didn't
very good but then how did the money
come back to the will that he left the
nephew died before the nephew died and
then the money went to the Americans mr.
Smith's you guys first then a few guys
Smithson died he bequeathed his money to
the nephew and were the nephew to die
without issue the money would go to the
Americans the nephew lived for five or
six years after and then yeah
what will get the money only if your 20
year old
well I think the Americans even knew I
don't think they were notified until the
nephew died the nephew died and then the
Americans were and then president was
received word that this money was
available and they sent the emissary
over to get it I don't think they were
aware of it certainly not at the at the
at that level he died and then and then
it went back to the executor xand the
executor had to notify the next in line
yeah the Americans beam in ashington
mm-hmm more details on this jar oh well
Arkansas when the money arrived Arkansas
was the most recently instated state
most recently his most recent state and
they had one senator and his name was
Ambrose savvier not probably not
pronouncing it properly SE VI ER may be
severe anyway he was the Godfather of a
political family in Arkansas that was
basically noted for its violence dueling
although he had he had gotten himself
elected on a platform opposing duels he
was actually he owed his position to a
duel at some point his uncle I think had
died in a duel and then he took this
anyway very violent guy very what they
could he was an exemplar of what they
called the Barbarian style the New York
Times described these this man as now a
creature of the West that only could
exist in the United States of America
you know they spitting and I mean that's
probably why they had the spittoons and
there were a lot of men who followed
this style but he was sort of one of the
one of those guys and what happened was
they invested the money in these bonds
on the state of Arkansas
really as a non-germane amendment to a
bill before the gold had even arrived in
the United States and so it was it was
invested and it stopped paying and the
reason that we know that so VA was
involved in it is that sometime after
well first of all atoms named doesn't
name him but he says that scoundrel from
Arkansas and the scheming senator from
Arkansas in his diary so we know that
Adams thought that this guy had made off
with it we know the money went to
arkansas state bonds and we know that it
disappeared there and then we also know
that the arkansas the senator from
Arkansas was later censured for
something involving commingling funds
with state bonds so all these little
clues together led me to believe that
this guy had and made off with it he and
his cronies I mean this was a time when
Arkansas was they were just building the
state capital and it was so corrupt that
they had to stop building the state
capital because somebody stole all the
money that was meant to build this
building it was a very wild place so
that's where it went mm-hmm you know
whether this city a was nephew son to
the severe spelled the same way
Tennessee East Tennessee one of the
first governors in Tennessee hey I would
assume so I mean it's not that common a
name it's not like Smith so and it's the
same area but I don't know for a fact
now I'm just guess their own politic
there in politics and the family
business the did any other questions
well thank you so much for coming Nina
Burleigh has contributed to Time
magazine The Washington Post and Us
Weekly her book the stranger in the
Statesman is published by william morrow
online at harpercollins calm in place of
public lives next week will show the
miami book fair